Let's discuss a few more visual cues, the
first of which is going to be direction. Direction
is similar to angle, but the direction encoding relies
on a single vector's orientation in a coordinate system.
By looking at the slope of a given line,
we can easily see increases, decreases, or fluctuations within
our data. However, direction is tricky for many of
the same reasons that angle is tricky. We can
easily differentiate a horizontal or vertical line, but when
we're dealing with lines with angles it's harder to
see the difference between two that are both negative
or positive. Another encoding that can be used is
shape. Shapes and symbols are commonly used to differentiate
categories of objects. For example, say that we had
a scatter plot. We could use triangles and squares
to show trends for two different types of data,
say two different baseball teams, or two different
districts in our Aadhaar data, something like that. We
can also use the area or volume of our
shapes to encode information. So bigger objects typically represent
greater values. Like length, when we encode information within
an area or a volume, we are basically representing
our data with size. So, say we were using
circles. The greater the value of the data point,
the bigger our circle is going to be.